voilà pascal sevran et alan je vois je
vois tu as call que vous portez votre
légion d'honneur
oui je trouve pour venir chez toi ça
faisait plus chez bien on peut voir de
voirie sur deux guerres non on peut voir
votre blessure de guerre le mérite
agricole non pourquoi pas je reviens
alors résumé des épisodes précédents
pascal a organisé sur france 2 un
concours de chanteurs et de chanteuses
intitulé entrée d'artistes 5000
candidats 400 audition 40 sélectionné
quatorze finalistes et un vainqueur
allan
[Musique]
m
et on voit des garçons
vous êtes des garçons
tous
ils sont des enfants des enfants qui
sont sains
tous les ans inquiète pour les quatre
1999 tout ça du s2j free la sélection
écoute bien le début
oui
des filles aiment défi à l'âme j'ai bien
compris pascal fille et mes filles
c'est une chanson qui a créé des leaders
ya trente ans que françois ozon a repris
dans son film à et kahlan a entendu dans
ce ce film est ma prose et de la chanter
chansons ont créé par dalida qui n'avait
pas exactement son âge à ce moment là et
j'ai été étonné le voir qu'il avait
choisi cette chanson il la chante et je
trouve qu'elle est beaucoup de
l'intensité les téléspectateurs l'ont
pensé aussi je continue à le penser
voilà quand tu es sérieux comme ça
j'adore je suis dans ce n'est pas une
question je te réponds voilà d'accord
t'as pas la voix de mon physique mais tu
as une belle voix mais t'as pas la boîte
ton physique
[Musique]
pour ne pas vivre seul des filles aiment
des filles de notre faute
voilà c'est ça qu'il entendait c'est
vachement bien je ne sais pas c'est une
attaque et la jalade j'ai 17 ans attend
c'est des trucs
voilà alors ce morceau ce morceau ce
morceau est extrait de la compil
officiel entrée d'artistes vous
connaissez orlando halal je le connais
un petit peu puisque je connais un petit
peu le parcours d'hélène ségara way et
don carlo forcément vous savez qu
orlando exige le clip vous savez ça vous
vous tenez comme mitterrand il ya des
références plus déplaisante que celle là
non je n'en ai pas et sait pas pourquoi
bah oui c'est juste pour montrer que je
me le demande jamais à l'abri de solutré
avec où c'était pour dire cher bruno
gaccio tout le monde le sait voilà bien
sûr mais pourquoi c'est sa fidélité
référence au nord voilà si sa fidélité à
mitterrand faut que sa mère n'est pas la
mer alors non mais je vous préviens je
pousse déficit donc vous allez regarder
votre caméra l'âme et vous allez dire
magnéto serge magnéto serge
[Applaudissements]
sans manches à une et toi qu'on ne pas
vivre seul
je t'aime et je t'attends on se donne
l'illusion de ne pas faire
russell
voir aller
alors vous vous êtes le vainqueur il ya
treize finalistes qui reprennent les
grands succès de la chanson française
sur cette compil entrée d'artistes est
le clip il est ratée sans déconner ben
c'est pas un clip c'est un extrait les
initiants blanc pascal quand je pense
qu'on vous reprochez de de faire chanter
que des vieillards finalement fait
mentir la légende
vous voyez on avait tort ouais j'ai
toujours tout au long de l'exécution est
évident que je fais depuis longtemps
j'ai fait chanter toutes les générations
et est donc maintenant on est en fait
j'ai fait chanter aussi gras change et
je pensais que tu avais l'air content qu
est ce que tu as donc c'est à dire que
je ne sais pas tellement je suis venu en
voisin
et comme tu m'as fait l'amitié de
m'inviter j'étais content de venir pour
alan par ses impressionnants pour
laisser première émission de télévision
car quoi qu'on dise je crois qu'à très
grand tempérament chez ce garçon et donc
je suis venu parce que tu m'as faire et
gentillesse de l'invité de l'inviter
sans ça je vais très peu d'émissions de
télévision comme tu le fais et je n'ai
pas du tout envie de venir faire des
gugusses tri donc je réponds aux
questions que tu me poses
mais s'il s'agit de faire le clown ça
n'est pas mon métier tient là tu en as
compris oui
arrête de nous arrêter c'est pas non
plus une raison pour faire la gueule je
veux dire je ne fais pas la gueule je
réponds à tes questions avec plaisir je
suis content d'être là j'écoute tes
questions vous et moi ici s'agit par là
dieu existait super-six s'agit s'il
s'agit de ce petit jeu là je connais par
coeur je connaissais depuis longtemps
c'est la télévision c'est bien s'amuse
aussi mais quand je suis chez moi pas je
zappe un petit peu mais ça me fatigue un
peu
un don de baziège et écoute je réponds à
ce que tu veux parce qu'en général ces
questions sont pas forcément stupide
bien
alors pascal vous allez écrire une
chanson pour le premier album a eu plein
de sourires haha
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon j'ai eu mon premier sourire c'est
bien mais je les adore ont plus rien les
yeux qu'il advient sont tournés ensemble
qu'on voit du vin blanc quoi parle
littérature et politique
ce soir on ne lui parlait un peu chanson
oui je ne vais pas tes exaspéré
longtemps pose moi ta question je
réponds maintenant pas d'accord alors la
question c'est pascal simon pas une
question d'ailleurs vous allez écrire
une chanson pour le premier album de
dahlan ça fait longtemps que vous n'avez
pas écrit de chansons j'ai pas écrit de
chansons depuis très longtemps je ne
suis pas sûr que je vais en écrire
voilà donc peut-être à une chanson c'est
pas l'objet je ne suis pas le producteur
de la tournée je suis pas le producteur
de disques c'est pas l'auteur des
chansons suis l'homme
je suis l'homme qui fait de son mieux
pour sur les services publics ouvrir une
fenêtre sur une génération
ils sont pas mal c'est simple dit saint
nicolas
alors
vous avez déclaré en parlant d' alan ils
brûlent d'un feu intérieur et ça se voit
quand il sourit oui certains marchés
vous savez il y avait comme ça soit 7
500 audition et puis un moment donné
voilà on se dit c'est lui ou c'est elle
est évidemment c'était lui voilà je ne
suis pas absolument abrutis quand je
parle de chanteurs aussi intéressant que
bruno gaccio
quand ils parlent de liberté
d'expression est aussi drôle alors un
lan ont parlé d' alan maintenant à l'âne
vous êtes originaire de la somme d'un
petit village qui s'appelle friville
escarbotin et maintenant tu es à paris
4226 habitants voilà vos parents michel
et michel possède une petite entreprise
de rondelle alors vas-y tous les leviers
voilà j'ai regardé pense et personne
nous dira avec explique vasile centre
d'études en fait à fond n'a retenu tri
des rares cas pas le père chanteur ou la
mère chanteurs ou comédiens affaire qui
fait les tubes donc c'est bien pour lui
encore trois quarts d'heure il fait des
vannes très bon qui sourit fait 12 morts
famille quand même deux musiciens votre
père joue de la guitare et du trombone
votre grand-père du saxophone
votre soeur du pipeau savoir pareil que
précédemment on les ponce alors quand
vous apprenez l'existence du casting de
pascal sevran vous hésitez pas ce que
voulait pas commencer par la télévision
pourquoi ce que gérant jamais couru les
castings jamais été très attiré par ça
et j'ai tenté ma chance par presque par
hasard et je me suis rendu compte après
que c'était vraiment une très bonne
opportunité sur un chez pascal sevran le
jour du casting vous chantez amsterdam
et ça plaît pas parce qu'alain il est
très sec avec vous je suis arrivé je lui
ai demandé de chanter il m'a demandé ce
que je vais chanter j'ai dit amsterdam
une finance même chanson pour toi
évidemment quand je voyais ce petit
garçon dire amsterdam je trouve que
c'était une chanson trop grande pour lui
j'ai voulu qu'il s'exprime d'abord ce
répertoire à lui on verra après
il exige t il est évident que j'étais
évident que ça me parait brel c'est très
difficile on peut pas comme ça voilà
donc je lui ai dit attends pour on verra
plus tard été tué à chanter quoi sans
tache tld quand même de patrick bruel
gens vont pas jouer avec faut chanter
une mère de départ elle lui a pas trop
mal réussi ni à paris ni d'ailleurs
autant pascal avait été sec au casting
au temps après il a été chaleureux il
nous a beaucoup appris à tous à tous mes
copains
d'ailleurs des sons qui sont là derrière
entre copains très amis et c'est vrai
que depuis le début et nous alignons et
vous conseille vous conseille mais quoi
jeudi pour le collier riche en or il a
rien dit par le codis a continué m coli
je remarque ici se sont habillés comme
il voulait ouais je les fais ok puis
sont venus comme isabelle envie de venir
enfin tout ça c'est qu'on voulait voir
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
12 ans
ils seront
les people
elles sont quand même pas mal mais ce
titre très bien mené qui vient toit dont
vous êtes la nouvelle bande de pascal
sevran
vous avez vous changé quelque chose là
alors amsterdam
oui c'est ça aussi c'est tout à fait une
chanson de groupe satam est une une
chanson green joie amour chance aux
chansons chantées et voilà tout
ou bien d'abord merci
[Musique]
tu sens par alain tu te fais plein de
nouveaux copains avec cette émission
finalement ils sont très bien
ouais ils sont très bien le dis pas ici
tu m' annonçait la mort de quelqu'un non
parce qu'on peut seule elle aborde la
chanson déjà je peux je vais montrer au
sérieux je veux dire ils ont comme ça
ils sont ils font ça très bien c'est
vraiment ils sont dix ans très bien ils
sont émus ils sont contents et ça de ne
pas envie de faire de la plaisanterie là
dessus voilà grave c'est grave sans
déconner l'agenais les chanteurs de la
jeunesse et la passion la jeunesse et la
passion que m ces jeunes gens à leur
métier c'est en effet très important
donc je suis content de voir les
parrainer chez j'ai tiré ce soir à la
mpt pascal ne s'est pas contenté de lui
donner votre chance il vous donne aussi
des conseils alors justement on va tous
en profitent et pascal quels conseils
donneriez-vous à un jeune chanteur qui
débute d'abord une détermination
formidable c'est l'idée qu'on ne veut
faire ça et rien d'autre deuxième chose
ne surtout pas s'occuper d'être à la
mode parce que là c'est raté comme un
nom puisque à peu près dans toute
l'histoire de la chanson française
ils sont à l'abri de ça écoutez suffi
aux joueurs mais je retiens ma phrase
parce que sans ça je finis ma phrase il
s'agit des jeunes gens moi j'en ai rien
à faire je deviens partir le gugusse ici
je finis ma phrase et je hais je vous
dis que il n'y a pas d'exemple quasiment
de vedette de music hall de la chanson
française qui ont qui sont arrivés en
semoule en se couchant dans la mode
voilà alors vous poser une question gsm
vous réponds du club on voit aussi donc
l'idée simplement ne pas se gavent aller
courir par serveur dans la mode parce
que le temps ne la rattrape et elle est
déjà passé d'accord quels conseils
donneriez-vous un vieux chanteur qui
débute encore d'être en bonne santé
chantier toujours tout parce que il faut
il faut pas employer ces jeunes ces
adjectifs qui review vous allez être
bientôt que je suis depuis longtemps
bien quels conseils donneriez-vous à
pascal sevran jeune je donnerai un
conseil à pascal sevran
à cette heure ci doit être couché
bonsoir
et voilà
[Musique]
cette part est l'ambiance générale
j'suis là père pascal se rend mon pote
jean reno alors savoir chanter mais
apparemment quels conseils
donneriez-vous à pascal sevran jeunes de
continuer à faire ce qu'il a fait parce
que mine de rien il a servi la chanson
française une certaine façon chanson
française que je n'achète pas et que je
n'achèterai sans doute jamais mais au
moins il a servi à ça la télévision et
continue commence à parvenir à gaza
quels conseils donneriez-vous un
chanteur qui ne veut pas de conseils de
pascal sevran et ben écoute parce
qu'elles souffrent c'est pas des
conseils bien est-ce que la lame connais
bien la chanson française vous croyez
maïs icônes et amsterdam de brel il
connaît la chanson française vient
jamais toi latif yahia allait investir
baisse mais toi tu fais ce grand ouest
jean tigana et la cité compte sur moi
pour faire sur ma fille de l'actionnaire
en accord avec toi la plage de secondes
sinon moi pour moi si tu veux un collier
ahmed bien est-ce que alan que vais bien
ma chanson française
alan connaîtra demain la chanson
française est-ce que alan c'est que
charles trenet nous a quittés alan ne
sait pas que charles trenet nous a
quittés il faut pas lui dire pascal
année sensible syrie est-ce que alors on
va faire un petit jeu là là je vais vous
dire des gens car si vous allez me dire
mort ou pas mort d'accord aller allons-y
reggiani morpho et heureusement
mouloudji morts richard anthony vivant
nino ferrer nord bien l'âme bien il
connaît bien la chanson de georges
moustaki
vivant vivent très bien à l'âme est ce
que pascal vous a déjà dit tu sais tu as
un truc bruel n'avait pas à ses débuts
ces gels d'avoirs
dubus écoute pascal bats la gueule je
suis désolé les corrections de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus